but there's a lingering issue here
because a lot of people say to me they
say
you know what's all this long-term
thinking all about you know it's so
difficult
and governments are so hopeless why
don't we just have benign dictators come
along and sort it all out for us
what we really need many people say are
enlightened despots and there is a
growing movement
of people believing this on both the
left and right the green
and the non-green well that's an
interesting idea to think about isn't it
is it actually true that authoritarian
governments are better
at delivering on long-term public policy
goals
and one might intuitively think yes or
just look at china aren't they great at
long-term
green infrastructure investment or look
at singapore
aren't they fantastic at their long-term
investment in housing and public health
care
so i thought about this and thought well
let's look at the evidence and in my
book the good ancestor
i actually look empirically at whether
dictatorships perform better than
democracies when it comes to long-term
thinking
and the way it's done in the book is
that i draw on a new index of
intergenerational solidarity
developed by a statistician called jamie
mcquilkin this is i think the best
long-term index in the world and it has
10 different indicators from three
different
areas which are put together so there
are environmental
indicators such as the amount of
renewable energy in the system
there are indicators of social matters
such as
uh investment in health care and then
there are there are economic indicators
such as inequality
they're put together into a single
number and then 122 countries are ranked
and in the rankings you can see that the
top performing countries in the world
are places like iceland and sweden but
also many non-wealthy countries such as
nepal or sri lanka and of course you
can't see china there china's down at
number 25 the uk is 45 the united states
is number 62.
there's a lot of variability in terms of
long-term policy performance
but then there's the question of what
how do these perform when it comes to
democracy and dictatorship well have a
look at this
this scatter plot shows the
intergenerational solidarity index
on the bottom axis and on the y-axis
going upwards is a measure of democracy
called the v dem liberal democracy
measure and what you see there
is that the little dots of countries
clustering the top right and the bottom
left
that means the more democratic you are
the more long-term your public policy is
going to be
and the less democratic you are the
less long-term your public policy is
going to be in fact of the top
25 countries on the intergenerational
solidarity index 21 of them are
democracies
of the 25 bottom scoring countries on
the intergenerational solidarity index
21 of them were autocracies and i think
this really puts an
end in a way to that benign dictatorship
argument
there is no systematic empirical
evidence that
autocracies outperform democracies when
it comes to long-term public policy in
fact
quite the opposite and this is not
saying that democracies can rest easy
they all need to deepen
their democracy and inject more
long-term thinking into their decision
making
but certainly the idea that the
dictatorship is going to solve all our
problems
is something that we have to i think
leave to the dustbin
of history